The answer is not necessarily.
We can't guarantee that m and n are relatively prime.
What we know is that n is pq, which are prime, and we know that m is less than n.
But it's possible that m is some multiple of p or some multiple of q.
Those could still be less than n if c1 is less than q or c2 is less than p,
but that would mean that m and n are not relatively prime.
That means that we can't use Euler's theorem directly.
We'd have to deal with these special cases.
That's a little kink in our correctness proof. I'm not going to go through those details.
They're not too interesting, but we're real close, and we're going to assume
that we can deal with this detail, and now we have the invertibility property
that we need for RSA to be correct.
One useful thing to notice here is that this works in both directions.
What we wanted for signatures was invertibility
where we do decryption first and then encryption..
That's equal to c^de mod n, which is also congruent to c mod n.
We'll have correctness in both directions.